And this video,
we'll see an efficient algorithm for
training or restrictive Boltzman machine
known as contrasted divergence.
It's
so we've seen a poster machine how it
defines a distribution over x and it's
hidden layer h. Uh, we've seen that, uh,
we could also write down p of x,
uh,
using the free energies
and we've looked at uh,
how exactly it tries to model an increased
probability for certain values of the
input vector that's actually see how,
uh,
we can actually train the restrictive
bolsa machine UNSOM training data, uh,
in order to obtain, they were suitable
to machine that model as well,
that data and assigns
high probability to it.
Okay.
So like we've seen before,
we'll treat this problem of training
as an empirical minimization problem,
uh, will, uh, do without the
regularization here and just, uh,
tried to minimize the average loss
where the loss is going to be the most
natural thing here to do,
which is to use the negative log
probability as our last for this model.
And so what we'd like to do
is optimize this average,
a negative log probability
of the training data, uh,
using an optimization procedure and
particular would like to use to castigate
the scent because works well and
scales well to large data sets.
And so it means that to achieve this
I need the partial, they'll live,
have any parameter theater of my loss.
Now if I make the derivation and write
down the expression for it actually has
a,
uh,
an expression which looks kind of similar
to other things we've seen before in
terms of partial the lives of parameters
for neural networks. We have again,
a difference of two terms.
One which depends on the observation
and another one which depends on more
explicitly,
only on the model.
And so this partial derivative
is going to be the, uh,
expect expectation over,
uh, what we never see,
which is the hidden layer value of
the partial narrative of the energy.
With respect to my parameter,
a given my observation.
So an expected,
a partial derivative,
we have to do an expectation because h we
never know where its value is. And, uh,
so it's the expectation of this partial
there live condition on the observation.
And then we subtract that,
the expectation over age and uh,
and now also ex, uh, of the
again, uh, the partial, the,
the, the energy function with
respect to our parameter,
but not as now we do an expectation
over x as well. And, uh,
this is an expectation according to
our model. So under our models, uh,
distribution, uh, so we often
refer to that part computing,
this part of the,
uh,
gradient as the positive phase and this
the negative phase for obvious reasons.
And, uh, but now the problem is that, uh,
this part here is actually hard to
compute. It's generally intractable. Uh,
and the reason is that we
have to make an exponential,
some over both h and x. And so, um,
perhaps you'll be convinced that if I
give you a value of the visible layers,
so if I give you an observation x,
then summing over h is actually
something that's tractable to do, uh,
for this partial derivative
in particular for the RBM. Uh,
and then we can again leverage the
fact that we get an expression,
a of nested nested sums,
a over something that fact arises
with respect to each hidden unit.
And then we can actually write this down
into an expression that's cylinder and
the number of hidden units.
So we'll see that more in more
details later in this video. Uh,
but now if you have to do
is some over both x and h,
now this becomes intractable. And so we'll
have to approximate that term somehow,
uh, in order to perform a stochastic
gradient descent efficient.
Okay.
So, uh, to address this problem,
Jeff Hinton in 2002 propose the
contrast divergence learning algorithm.
Uh, so there's some theory for
what this is actually doing.
I'm not going to go over that.
I'm just going to describe what the
algorithm is and the more intuitive terms.
And, uh, I tried to give more intuition
for why it should actually work.
So really the idea is to try to,
uh,
do without this double expectation
and a instead estimated.
So are there are really three main
components to a contrasted divergence.
The first idea is that the expectation
over x and h in the negative phase will
actually replace it by a point
estimate at a single observation excel.
So the expectation over X,
we'll replace it by a a point estimate
at axtel because if we have that point
estimate, if we give me a
value of the visible layer,
then I can do the expectation over age
and then get an estimate of the uh,
double expectation.
Uh,
so that's just really saying we'll do a
Monte Carlo estimate of the expectation
with a single data point. Then, uh, we'll,
we need to obtain that extent somehow.
Uh,
and ideally would like to a
sample from the true distribution,
not the true distribution,
but our model distribution.
And then we'll do this by Gibbs
sampling. Uh, so remember that Gibbs,
something corresponds to a sampling,
each variable in my model,
given the others,
and specifically for a restricted Bolsa
machine performing that sampling is
actually quite as efficient
because condition on one layer,
all the other elements and the
other layer, uh, are independent.
Then I can sample all the
values in one layer in parallel,
given the value, uh, of the opposite
layer and then alternate between,
uh,
each layer like this.
And so this is actually very
efficient to do in practice.
And then the third idea,
which is perhaps the most
important contribution behind
contrasted divergence is
to uh,
perform gib sampling.
But by starting our assembling at,
uh,
a state where the visible layer,
is set to the training example for which
I'm trying to compute the gradient and
do an update.
And so instead of starting like we
usually do and give sampling at a
configuration of my, uh, on my
layers, my random variables,
that is a simple, uh, perhaps uniform the,
and just randomly according to some of
initial distribution out actually use the
value of the training observation for the
value of the visible they are when I'm
performing gib sampling.
And the other thing is that I'm,
I'm not actually going to
do give sampling for a long,
I'm actually going to do it for one,
two,
or just a few iterations and a,
as we'll see,
this actually works well in practice.
So to illustrate this process more
visually. Uh, so there's, oh, Aaron,
my finger, there should be a
little the same circle here.
So what we'll do is that at training
time for giving training example,
I'll take the value of the input vector
x and I'll set it as my value from my
visible layer.
Then I'll assemble all the hidden
units condition on the observing this
particular value of the visible there.
This training example.
So I'll sampled from p of h given that
x is equal to x t in this case here,
uh, just a note on performing
that sampling. So, um,
each neuron lung condition independent,
so they each have Bernoulli
for which I can compute.
What's the probability for
that Bernoulli random variable,
that hidden unit being holed to one,
given x.
Now to obtain a sample from a Bernoulli,
would that probability
of being equal to one,
what I can do is just sample from a
uniform distribution between zero and one.
And then if that value,
that uniform value that I
sampled is actually, um,
uh, sorry, it should be
the other way around.
So if this value is greater
than so greater than,
uh, the value of the probability is
greater than the value of sample from my
uniform, then I'm going to set the, um,
that I'm going to set the hidden layer,
unit digit hidden layer,
the unit two I want. And
otherwise I'm going to set it
to zero. So in other words,
the value of the hidden yet is going to
be the identity function of whether the
probability of the hidden unit is greater
than a random sample from a uniform
between zero and one. So we can
see that this, uh, will be, uh,
equal to one with a
probability of this value, uh,
because the mass of a
uniformly distributed random
variable between zero and
this value is going to be
exactly because it's uniform,
it's going to be p of d
people to one given x. So, uh,
so indeed the property that this is one
is going to BP of Hg equal one given
x.
Okay. So now I've taken my
training sample. I've simple
each of the hidden units,
uh, conditionally, uh,
a condition on the physical
layer of taking that value.
And then I'm going to reconstruct a,
uh,
the visible layer by sampling from a p
of x given the current value of my hidden
there.
So I could call this a x one.
And then I'm going to
do that four k steps.
I'm going to take x one and then
sample the new value of the hidden.
They're given my previously
sample value of the visible layer.
I'm going to alternate light this
performing Gib sampling for case steps.
And now this last value after I've
done my case steps is going to be the,
uh, a negative sample x still. So Xcel,
we often refer to it as a negative sample,
which is used to estimate the
negative phase part of the gradient.
And so I'm going to use that
as my negative sample to
perform my point estimate
of the expectation,
uh,
over X. Okay. So visually,
what does this look like?
So I get a training example and uh,
in the positive phase I'd had to
estimate this conditional expectation to
simplify. Imagine I actually don't
perform my expectation. I just sample and,
uh,
h given this XD and I'll
call that h tilty and uh,
I've also performed case
steps of Gib samplings,
[inaudible] and similarly how to perform
that expectation estimated at exhale
and h still wear,
uh,
age still would be simple based on the
conditional distribution of the hidden
layer,
given that x is equal to x still.
Okay.
Um,
so then I get these two pairs and if I
look at the green in the sense procedure,
what it's telling me is that I should
decrease the energy at the training
observation and I should increase it
at the simple value x still in its
associated hidden layer. Uh, because uh,
low energy means high probability,
then this means that I'm going
to increase really the, uh,
probability of observing
XT with a tendered layer.
And I'm going to at the same time,
the probability that x still is
going to be observed under my models
distribution.
And so if my training example
corresponded to images of digits,
then I'd be increasing the probability
of observing this particular digit here
under my model.
And then say initially my uh,
restricted bolsa machine
is randomly initialized.
So it essentially corresponds to a uniform
distribution over a binary vectors.
Then initially what I'm going to sample
is really going to look like noise.
Essentially it's going to
look like something like this.
And so what I'll be doing is then making
the probability of sampling something
like this from my model and much smaller
and then I'll continue iterating like
this. So next time around it will be less
likely that it still would look like a
random image and the sample value for
exterior going to be looking more and more
like actual training examples because
I keep pushing down the probability of
anything that doesn't look like a digit.
And so we can see that as
we keep sampling like this,
then eventually the gradient should
become smaller because the value of XD is
going to be more and more similar
to the sample value of exhale.
And so until they lead this algorithm,
what it's doing is that it's
increasing the, uh, energy, uh, sorry,
decreasing the energy of things that look
like what's in the training set while
increasing the energy of things that,
uh,
are as elucidated or sample by the model.
And we keep doing this until the
model spits out or generates, uh,
observations that are very similar to
what's in the model. In other words,
it's become a good model
of, uh, uh, our dataset.